the Napa Valley Film Festival Vanessa
Hudgens was honored with the visionary
award but of course ET was with Vanessa
way before that I want to do a little ET
flashback with you I have a clip here is
just from 2004 your very first ET
interview take a look at this oh my god
it's not every day you get to be a
rescue hero it's just amazing to see big
girls get to do rescue tear our you go
that's what happens when you don't wash
your face ready hit I'm gonna keep
talking about myself and say yes girl
you wanted to do action and now you're
in the next bad boys camo is a high
school musical boyband wit gun bad boys
for life perfect segue Vanessa well is
just like a burst of energy mm-hmm
they were like sending gifts to my
trailer like on the weekly you know it's
like this is not normal this is just too
sweet we love Vanessa even more for
bringing back High School Musical at a
recent karaoke night Michelle hosted the
celebrity tribute with Vanessa Kevin
Bacon and spotlight award winner Jillian
Bell the two chattered at Raymond
vineyards talking all about her weight
loss transformation while shooting
Britney runs a marathon actually lost 40
pounds 29 pounds before we started
shooting 11 pounds during shooting she's
the last time that will ever happen
because craft services are very good
they really are the devil they're
delicious we have to make the eye
contact Cheers
I just found out what that means if you
don't make the icon what does it mean
boy years of bad luck know a fella told
me that it means seven years of bad sex
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]